they will under my proposal not what
you've said but it's not what that party
is saying that is simply the party
doesn't say
i'm the one that brought back football
by the way i brought back big ten
football
nice i brought back taffy this is a joke
debate why is nobody laughing
wait this is the real thing this is
absurd what are we even watching i can't
get in a word i don't criticize
supporters however zany so stand down
and stand by ayatollah khamenei would
you shut up
that's how it's presented we'll back up
on my way you're about to get our
presidential rule of law is important on
that we agree
that's why if i lose i will never
concede fake news is a problem it's
breaking the nation it's wait a minute i
gotta retweet this misinformation
he's stronger than the military please
don't bother he's going through generals
like the harlem globetrotters they're
dropping like flies i'm your ideal pick
he's lost more mad dogs than michael
vick a return to normalcy wouldn't that
be endearing a time of civility like the
kavanaugh hero who would even want this
job he'd have to be a fool and had a job
this bad since i cleaned jerry falwell's
he's better on covert i'd have to make
an objection i've seen essential oils
with better virus protection shoot i'm
gonna get emails
not the best placement mr biden can i
hide in your basement
undecided voters i offer this take you
both have a very important decision to
make
that is totally totally this can't be
the new normal do i get my time back